[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on les a mis à côté parce que les deux
c'est des frères de voyance
de soudeur on voit pas grand-chose
vous voyez bien vous voyez bien j'ai mes
yeux qui ont été brûlés
et je vais vous dire voilà il est très
gentil il fait jamais de mauvaise langue
voilà et alors on compte vraiment sur
vous on est sur les chroniqueurs et sur
également voilà alors pour vérifier donc
tout ça pour être rassuré ou pas on a
essayé de demander donc votre avis
évidemment alors ça commence par un truc
un petit peu glauque je suis désolé on
sera au César mais sur ma figée selon
vous voici des personnalités amenées à
nous quitter en 2023
c'est selon alors pardon c'est selon un
voyant américain donc coup de bol il
vous connaît pas parce qu'il t'imagine
dans la liste
en attachant
donc selon non seulement en voyant
américain voilà les gens qui vont
disparaître en 2023 je vous le dis
Charles III
de rencontrer hier mais c'est pour ça
que j'ai essayé de faire un dock la
contaminécologique tu leur donnes
fortune derrière je peux te dire
Bruce Willis vous savez qu'il est très
malade et que ça va mal Bill Gates
John Travolta non ah non pas John
Travolta
salut sinon Jack Nicholson 90 ans
Michael J Fox
pourvu que si je regarde pas la télé
française Whoopi Goldberg Kathleen
Jenner Demi Lovato Ozzy Osborn et alors
pour vous dire la vérité parce que il en
met une couche il dit voilà les gens qui
vont mourir et je préviens que j'avais
déjà vu il avait l'année d'avant il
avait annoncé l'arrestation de Bill
Cosby et
donc si vous voulez il y a un petit
moment où tu te dis tiens il a peut-être
bon après c'est sympa pour les gens
là acheter les cd les machins et ça ça
va prendre une valeur il a pris des gens
très vieux et malade donc il se dit avec
un peu de chance et Charles III le
pauvre il est aussi sur la liste ce
qu'on appelle la Death list aux
États-Unis qui est publié tous les 1er
janvier quelle est la liste des 50
prochaines personnes qui vont
disparaître dans l'année qui est hyper
glauque et le roi Charles III
malheureusement lui aussi y est sauf que
la Death liste a eu alors maintenant on
commence avec vous
non non je vous dis c'est un peu
sinistre comme lisse et dans tous les
journaux moi j'étais à François au
Figaro on a des gens qu'on met au frigo
on sait qu'ils sont pas bien et on
commence à préparer les pages sont
prêtes on a plus qu'à appuyer sur un
bouton
je pense que tout le monde a déjà prévu
sa bio sur de longs par exemple
j'adore ces news et je les embrasse mais
ils ont fait là pendant les vacances de
Noël ils ont fait venir pareil voyante
et être un coup je suis qui vous voyez
partir j'ose pas monsieur qui vous voyez
lancez-vous écoutez je pense que Benoît
16 mois cette année ah bah oui merci
chérie merci et Max Verstappen François
du monde alors les prédictions des stars
on y va on va parler de Céline Dion
alors Céline Dion Céline Dion je l'ai
mise avec justement le prince Charles
merde
avec pas tout de suite un peu de temps
quand même alors Céline Dion est le
prince Charles de malade malheureusement
et le prince Charles problème de santé
fin d'année 2023 intervention
chirurgicale et pour Céline Dion pas de
retour à la scène du tout
[Musique]
annoncé elle-même
européenne n'était pas annulée la
tournée européenne n'était pas lunée oui
mais pas en Europe
merci beaucoup attention c'est fou vous
aussi vous voyez qu'il va avoir un
problème
bien précisé
le foie le foie le foie
on rigole
[Applaudissements]
sur Charles en ce moment
papa fait 2023 mais c'est génial mais
c'est qui la maman
vous avez la date de la conception
[Musique]
[Rires]
exactement et qui soit heureux et c'est
très très bien Florent Pagny oh mon
petit Florent alors nous savons qu'il se
battent se bat bien et sera avec nous
encore
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est une très bonne nouvelle et je
peux dire que en décembre j'étais en
vacances j'ai pris deux trois jours de
vacances seulement je disais la presse
people pardon Je te regarde mais il y
avait des il se bat contre ce cancer
va-t-il revenir
pourra-t-il faire ça tourner va-t-il
mourir j'ai envie de leur dire mais en
plus de 2023 c'est l'année de la douceur
j'en ai leur dire mais pour y pas
arrêter de faire chier donc les
premières à révéler qu'il était
guéri d'ailleurs le mot est un peu fort
au départ
en tout cas non c'est vrai mais
alors avec son procès alors on a marqué
Laetitia Hallyday
jusqu'en fin
2026 problème histoire
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge encore avec
cette encore trois ans moi j'ai adoré
dans son doc franchement dans son doc
elle est des deux choses elle a dit
pardon Johnny mais je t'en veux tu étais
égoïste égocentrique tu t'es est tu n'as
rien prévu de la presse
j'ai rejoint Johnny
il a il a après moi le déluge j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] une star petit 1 et puis
elle m'a touché quand elle a dit Johnny
l'a trompé mais c'est de ma faute hein
j'étais j'étais pas j'étais pas assez
présente à la maison je m'occupais pas
de mes enfants ça je vais la reprendre
quand je trouverai mon mec
et en même temps sur une minute 45 de
doc une image de David une image de
Laura
comme ça
elle a des flashs et donc elle est toute
douce
très très peu alors
parce que j'ai pas sur ma fiche
Cyril Hanouna
alors Cyril écoute-moi écoute-moi bien
il y a une mauvaise nouvelle une partie
vivre en Alaska
alors Cyril alors Cyril Hanouna enfin
l'amour au grand jour ah bon grosse
décision
[Applaudissements]
mon bébé tu n'avais jamais dit
ah mais voilà première dame sur un
bateau me voilà
ah mais du coup faut que ce soit une
séquence télé alors
oui
Cyril
une grosse tu peux dire quand même
parler différemment régie une grosse
décision professionnelle à prendre on va
en prendre une année là octobre
septembre on a pas encore décidé on va
avoir ce qu'on fait mais on va aller
vivre à Sainte-Maxime si on parlait de
Mathieu Delormeau oui
attention
un peu de boisson sans machin parce
qu'en ce moment je bouffe cette année
allez-y alors à la recherche d'un
véritable amour
ma mère vient de me marier
juin important pour l'amour
[Rires]
je suis contente de vous retrouver
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a dit oui très
important
c'est la même chose
toute façon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ensuite ensuite on a qui ensuite on a
fini avec toi c'est vrai quoi
donc l'amour en juin
et le plus important c'est le boulot
mais alors c'est bien mais le boulot
signature de contrat important
renouvellement
mais vous savez que ce matin j'avais
deux messages c'était numéro inconnu si
ça se trouve j'ose même pas où l'ouvrir
devant vous ça peut être Fabien
automniente
[Rires]
c'est pas un ego vous pourrez demander
un petit assistant que j'adore j'en ai
perdu quatre cette année même l'URSSAF a
demandé si c'était pas un absent me
préparer toute ma famille et en fait
vous savez pourquoi Jean-Pierre une fois
dans un dans un dans une salle de sport
il l'aura donné ils ont dit bah c'est de
leur mot j'en ai perdu un à une fois
dans un taxi le mec très gentiment à
appeler et en fait bah on voit comme
c'est connu et voilà et puis je me kiffe
quand même mais
donc oui donc projet important projet
important et renouvellement le
renouvellement
quoi EDF